je viens aujourd'hui vous donner
quelques astuces pour bien utiliser vos
airs pause 10 astuces pour les utiliser
au mieux cette vidéo s'adresse aussi
bien aux airs podz pro aux airs poste de
troisième génération reposent de
deuxième génération elle ne s'adresse
pas aux rps max qui sont un petit peu à
part alors en partie sur des fonctions
oui bien évidemment mais peut-être à
développer un contenu à part donc
aujourd'hui on va pas se parler des
reposes max mais l'astuce ou d une fois
de plus et repose pro airpol deuxième
génération est rose de troisième
génération bref la grande famille des
ipod
[Musique]
la première astuce hyper important parce
que c'est pour savoir si vous écoutez de
la musique trop forte on va commencer on
va se mettre un petit air pozzo masse
écouter un morceau de rammstein on va se
mettre un petit d'ouest et pour savoir
si j'écoute de la musique trop forte ou
pas eh bien regardez je suis dans mon
centre de contrôle et j'ai ici en bas
audition voulait s'appuyer dessus et là
vous voyez votre niveau au niveau des
décibels alors là bon ça va 72 décibels
mais si je monte ex bourrine boy tout de
suite c'est très fort et lâchés au max
90 93 et cybèle c'est vraiment pas y
aller alors il vous le dis un bruyant
que la droite soit en dessous voilà
c'est beaucoup plus agréable ça permet
de savoir si j'écoute de la musique
beaucoup trop forte envie de me flinguer
les oreilles là c'est calme mais cochon
environnement qui est extrêmement
brouillon je suis dans la rue j'en sais
rien il ya beaucoup de bruit et si j'ai
pas de réduction welti j'ai tendance à
pousser le volume et des fouilles allé
trop fort donc là je peux savoir si je
vais trop fort ou pas trop fort et pour
revenir activer la partie audition il
faut que vous alliez ici vous allez dans
votre centre de contrôle et vous venez
ajouter l'audition qui en bas on peut
dire la montée si vous le souhaitez si
vous voulez le faire là directement ça
vous arrange et ça fait que vous allez
venir la retrouver ici et ça c'est
vachement intéressant c'est super bien
deuxième astuces et pour venir écouter
une conversation à distance la
fonctionnalité de base c'est de mieux
entendre une conversation elle peut être
détourné pour venir espionner des
personnages ce n'est pas pour venir
espionner des personnes mais en tout cas
vous vous serez alerté que cette
mentalité existe je vous montre comment
ça marche il faut que vous avez une fois
de plus dans vos réglages sans de
contrôle vous activez l'audition et vous
revenez ici dans vos paramètres vous
revenez dans audition et vous laisser
appuyé alors qu'est ce que vous faites
une femme vous êtes là vous allez dans
écoute en temps réel et vous venez
l'activé donc là je m'entends parlé dans
mon oreille c'est très très très
désagréable si vous voulez utiliser
comme elle est prévue bien vous posez
votre appareil à côté d'une personne qui
vous parle et vous l'écoutez par les
attentions le son est très médiocre la
qualité n'est pas dingue dingue et si
par exemple vous voulez écouter ce qui
se dit au fond de la pièce là bas
quelques uns parlent ils vous voulez
savoir ce qu'elle raconte est bien vous
prenez votre iphone vous le posez au
fond vous mettez vos écouteurs et vous
faites comme si vous écoutez de la
musique en fait vous écouter tout ce qui
se dit derrière alors méfiez vous si
vous voyez l'iphone de quelqu'un qui est
posée derrière et qu'il est en train
d'écouter de la musique mais vous n'êtes
pas sûrs qu'ils écoutent de la musique
peut-être qu'il entraîne vous espionner
il ou elle vous espionner donc ça il
faut le savoir troisième astuce si vous
n'avez pas de wifi vous n'avez pas trois
juges n'avaient pas de casier ou
d'ailleurs pas du tout fan si vous
n'avez rien du tout mais vous vous
l'écoutez des petits sons pour venir
vous détendre et bien vous pouvez le
faire exactement de la même manière ici
toujours au même endroit dans votre
centre de contrôle au niveau d'audition
vous allez ici dans son en arrière-plan
vous cliquez là la j'écoute de la pluie
ça c'est très très zen la pluie pour
venir changer de son alors la pluie
c'est un son qui va encore pas trop mal
on a le bruit équilibré espèce de bruit
blanc c'est pas terrible ça ne dépend
pas des masses bruit clair c'est encore
pire bruits sonores c'est une has océans
c'est pas fou y a vraiment plu qui est
bien il ya plus et cours d'eau prenons
ça donne envie de faire pipi donc si
vous avez envie de faire pipi n'écoutez
pas cours d'eau autre fonctionnalité qui
est vraiment super bien au niveau des
recrues ne sais pas si vous connaissez
ces leçons spatiale et le son spatial
c'est vraiment vraiment bien et vous
permettra d'avoir une distance beaucoup
plus immersive à ce que vous allez
regarder des films et des séries alors
je vous montre comment ça marche sont
spéciales vous venez laisser appuyer
directement là et là vous avez convertir
en son spatial alors là je vous ai mis
non vous êtes deux possibilités soit
vous le laisser en fixe comme il est là
soit vous le mettez avec le suivi de la
tête actifs lorsque vous êtes en fixe
vous à pouvoir venir bouger la tête vous
aurez toujours le son spatial de la même
manière ça changerait absolument pas si
maintenant vous l'activez avec le suivi
la tête actifs lorsque vous regardez un
film une série sur votre ipad sur votre
iphone et des cas ce qui va se passer la
scène restera devant et lorsque vous
allez bouger vous allez avoir
l'impression que le sort reste là bien
que vous bougez votre tête ça c'est
assez bluffant vous regardez une série
la voix est là haut up et d'un coup la
voix se trouve à droite dans votre
oreille oui pour rester avec votre écran
qu'il lui reste là et c'est la même
chose au couteau d ici le son arrivée
ici donc ça porte à un peu plus
d'immersion alors c'est pas non plus un
truc complètement dingue dingue on n'a
pas l'impression que le ce on arrive
d'en haut de derrière et compagnie on
est un peu plus immergé j'ai fait
l'expérience avec de la musique je
trouve ça assez rigolo non perd quand
même vraiment en précision au niveau du
spectre audio ça devient plus imprécis
et ça je n'ai pas de m'habiller der
poste de troisième génération donc si
vous n'avez pas vu aller la voir on une
autre astuce qui est très intéressante
et qui est assez méconnue de pouvoir
venir choisir sur voir paul quel micro
va être utilisée lorsque vous allez
faire passer un coup de fil alors ça
peut paraître un peu bête comme ça on
les a mais pourquoi est ce que je veux
choisir que sur le micro droit aux
micros de gauche il ya une vraie logique
là dedans imaginez un moment ou un autre
vous l'écoutez que d'une oreille vous
voulez garder l'autre libérer comme ça
c'est pas pourquoi ça peut arriver et
vous n'avez pas votre et tu as côté les
tuiles ailleurs vous mettez dans votre
petit repose dans la poche sauf que là à
l'intérieur vous avez un petit capteur
de présence et qu'est ce qui va se
passer bien lui si vous mettez dans la
poche il va considérer qu'il est sans
votre oreille si le petit capteur de
présence est obstruée et il va donc
pouvoir venir pourquoi pas
indépendamment choisir d'utiliser le
micro gauche ou le micro droit sauf que
micro droit il sera dans la poche et ça
pourrait être un peu ballot que vous
allez ici dans bluetooth vous serez
c'est votre appareil s'appuie sur le
petit juste à côté et vous allez tout en
bas sur micro par exemple ici moi j'ai
l'écouteur gauche eh bien vous
choisissez toujours l'airpod gauche ce
qui fait que il va utiliser toujours
leurs potes gauche pour venir passer les
côtes il pour utiliser un micro et pas
les points de droit donc si jamais la
pohdh droit et bien non ça ne sera pas
bon ce ne sera pas le bon micro donc il
faudra bien penser à ce moment là à
remettre au changement automatique c'est
une petite astuce mais peut être
intéressante dans certains cas d'usagé
autre astuce qui est vachement
intéressant c'est de pouvoir prendre un
appel téléphonique sans appuyer sur un
bouton ou sans décrocher directement
depuis votre téléphone grâce à vos leurs
potes et bah oui c'est complètement
possible qu'est ce qu'il faut faire vous
venez vous descendez vous avez
l'application de téléphonie dans
l'application téléphone vous venez juste
ici dans annonces d'appels alors qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans l' annonce
d'appel eh bien ça vous dira t'elle
personnes vous appelle vous voulez vous
décrochez et là vous dites oui ça
décroche automatiquement sans que vous
ayez besoin d'avoir une action en
touchant voir potes ou en touchant votre
iphone alors vous pouvez venir l'activé
uniquement software poste ou même si
vous souhaitez écouteurs et voiture
c'était dans la voiture sa énoncera à
l'appel et vous pouvez venir décrocher
en disant oui ou non autre astuce si
vous êtes dans un endroit où tout le
monde a des airs pop c'est à dire tous
leurs potes vont s'appeler repose si
vous voulez inviter quelqu'un me
regarder un film ou une série avec vous
et tout le monde a un truc super pote ça
marche pas donc ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à dire personnaliser le nom de
serre pose de la même manière vous venez
ici dans bluetooth vous allez retrouver
ici vous leur posez moi j'en ai
personnalisé aucun mot va le faire
ensemble rdr pause projet puis juste là
et là j'ai le nom et repose pro et moi
je mets tes potes progrès voilà et
lorsque mr paul piché dans la liste il
s'agira de venir les choisir eh bien je
saurai que ce sont les liens et c'est
extrêmement mal un autre astuce c'est
l'entretien parce que ces herbes folles
dont les projets utilisent beaucoup mais
il faut venir les nettoyer il ya un
plein plein en plus de petites
cochonneries et je suis millions contre
les sacs ils vont venir rester alors
chez s'exprime pas les nettoyer la
première vous les montrez vous en avez
quand même pas mal au niveau de l'étui
pas mal au niveau des écouteurs pour
nettoyer c'est à la fois très facile et
à la fois un peu complexe moi ce que je
vous conseille ici dans un premier temps
c'est ça les cotons-tiges alors apple
vous le dire ils vous disent attention
nettoyer les avec un petit chiffon doux
on n'est pas n'importe quoi dessus déjà
ça vous pouvez venir l'enlever et
repulse pro1 pas sur des reposes autres
avec votre petit coton tige vous venez
tout nettoyer à l'intérieur je veux pas
qu'ils restent des cochonneries le petit
embouts en silicone vous pouvez venir le
nettoyer avec de l'eau attention de
papier trop grand pour ne pas venir
abîmé cette partie là et ensuite vous
prenez votre écouteurs et vous allez
faire la même chose avec votre petit
coton tige tout le reste là où prenait
un petit chiffon sec voire un petit
chiffon légèrement humide attention pas
d'eau ici pas d'eau pas d'eau pas d'eau
pas d'eau historique et des petites
impuretés vous prenez un petit
cure-dents vous faites ça vient et que
ça brille à gratter un petit peu dessus
de la même manière sur la petite grille
ici là avec le cure dent on vient
gratouiller légèrement en est mignon et
on enlève et pour tout le reste ça va
être un petit chiffon un petit chiffon
légèrement humide si on souhaite s'il ya
des petites choses qui ne veulent pas
partir mais pas grand chose de plus sur
votre étui c'est la même chose petit
chiffon légèrement humide si vous le
souhaitez sur l'extérieur ont nettoyé
les connectiques ici de vous prenez un
petit cure dents et vous venez
gratouiller et enlever ce qu'il ya
dedans et vous allez voir il ya toujours
des surprises on n'abîme pas on y va
vraiment très très très doucement et
ensuite c'est pareil de la même manière
vous ouvrez petit coton tige et on vient
nettoyer tout doucement ici coton tige
légèrement humide si vous souhaitez mais
surtout pas au niveau des connectiques
l'a pas d'eau pas d'eau pas d'eau pas de
contact on vient on enlève tout mignon
tout doux on y va en force pas on va pas
forcer au niveau des connectiques on va
pas venir lui laisser un petit bout de
peluches dessus et si vous avez les
oliveaux airpod avec un petit chiffon
humide vous les laissez bien sécher
avant de le remettre dans les tuyaux
autre astuce intéressante vous avez vos
et reposez vous ne voulez pas qu'ils
viennent se connecter à votre iphone
tout le temps vous voulez qu'ils restent
connectés à votre ipad vous venez ici au
niveau de vos reer post up vous appuyez
dessus et là vous venez connecter à cet
iphone automatiquement et ben donc vous
mettez connaître cet iphone lors de la
dernière connexion à cet iphone ça veut
dire que si vous l'avez connecter un
ipad et bien lui il va plus venir se
connecter votre iphone automatiquement
ça sera à vous de venir dans les
paramètres pour le dire non maintenant
tu te connectes à l'iphone ça évitera
qu'on les déconnexions intempestives et
la 10e as tu savais tout bête mais elle
est vraiment bien c'est une notion
d'écosystème si vous voulez venir
contrôler le vol du son sont touchés à
votre iphone et bien vous le faites avec
votre apple watch et ça c'est un truc
que j'aime beaucoup beaucoup utilisé
lorsque je suis en déplacement lorsque
je suis par exemple dans un train ou
dans un avion j'écoute de la musique
avec mes impôts ce propos mais repose
max je viens le piloter directement le
monde parce que mon iphone est dans la
poche et hop je viens monter le son avec
ma des gîtes akron jeu m'a changé le
morceau directement depuis mon apple
ouest vous avez vu je n'ai pas tout de
suite mais je fais très facilement et ça
c'est une tout bête mais c'est une fois
de plus l'écosystème d'apple si vous
avez l'iphone d'apple au match et les
repose vous avez un combo qui marchent
vachement bien pour venir piloter tout
votre multimédia directement sans
toucher à votre iphone et ça s'est super
bien aller jouer dans une petite
dernière histoire se marrer c'est un
petit bonus et pour moi c'est cadeau si
vous avez un problème avec vos potes ça
peut arriver qu'un nain qui n'arrivent
plus à se connecter bien qu'il soit
reconnu et bien vous pensé aller
réinitialisé c'est un truc tout bête
première chose dans votre iphone r paul
drouot oublie cet appareil vous cliquez
dessus vous venez ici voulait s'est
appuyé pendant 30 secondes sur petits
boutons derrière jusqu'à ce que ça
devienne tout blanc ici c'est pour venir
l'écouter ensuite directement à votre
iphone et ça c'est extrêmement pratique
voilà pour ces quelques petites astuces
pour devenir optimiser l'utilisation de
ces aires pose est ce que vous les
connaissiez tout est ce que vous en
connaissez quelques-unes est-ce que vous
en avez d'autres voulaient marquer juste
en bas en commentaire on sera quelques
autres vidéos comme ça on donnera des
astuces très bientôt je les admire vous
abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait le
petit bouton rouge est juste là vous les
pieds dessus et vous activer la cloche
d'ici là je vous embrasse à très bientôt
des gros bisous prenez soin
[Musique]